do you think crispr
oh biology question do you think crispr
may be needed to stop covid if it
mutates too fast for traditional
vaccines
what are the major concerns you have
with this technology thanks and keep up
the great work
um i don't know if crispr
can be i'm not
it's been a while since i've thought
about crispr i don't know how it can be
used
to to address covet if it's mutating
really fast
um so it can be used it
doesn't it doesn't need to be used
because we have other techniques to do
the same thing which doesn't mean it's
not the most efficient way to do those
things
but the thing to understand about crispr
is that
i have analogized it to we have a
typewriter for
the language of genes and that
typewriter is crispr what we don't have
is the rosetta stone we the humans have
a typewriter the genes themselves have
whatever they've got genes do their
thing and we now have a typewriter that
allows us to make any sequence we like
right yeah we know what the letters are
we know what the letters are and we can
assemble them at will but we don't speak
the language of those letters yet we're
learning things about that language but
without the rosetta stone we don't speak
the language which means we can't sit
down and say
let's write a gene to do x and we've got
so much hubris
you know the the molecular biologists
are so sure that they've that they've
got this nailed in so many regards
um that changes are often done without
regard to
you know things like chesterton's fence
unintended consequences
it's it's dangerous so i would say i've
seen
um efforts in the neighborhood of
vaccines
and one of the efforts which is
currently being
suppressed it would seem by our top
level journals
makes the following point in their
manuscript about
vaccine technology which is um
these pathogens
have high variability in terms of
their rate of change and that a vaccine
that is
targeted at something that changes
rapidly is obviously a short duration
phenomenon and one can systematically go
through
the the uh the genome and the structures
and you can target things that change
less frequently which seems a very
obvious point but nonetheless
there are oh it also makes another point
which is target things that are as far
from human sequences as possible
right to the extent that the pathogen in
part profits by
disappearing against the backdrop of a
human you target the parts of it that
are most
different because those parts then do
not confuse the immune system into
attacking itself
and creating an autoimmune disease
that's good so there is a way to play
this game
and the idea that we are going to
because the vaccine
in question is being developed by people
who
through their research have discovered
just how probable it is that
the virus emerged from a laboratory
after having been modified
that we are going to shut down that
discussion and thereby
slow the progress on that vaccine is
appalling because
frankly that could very easily lead to a
great many needless deaths
[Music]
you